I'm very honest though in general after
speaking out against online hate Haley
Bieber shares a public thank you to
Selena Gomez I'm very lucky that I have
the platform I have on Friday the two
put up a united front on social media
both posting statements to their
Instagram stories Haley's message she
writes I want to thank Selena for
speaking out as her and I have been
discussing the last few weeks how to
move past this ongoing narrative moments
like this only create extreme division
instead of bringing people together on
social media it's as much as it's a
blessing and it's fun it it can really
tear people down and I always thought
that the people I'm involved with or
support me can just kind of spread love
within that this comes just hours after
cell told fans that Haley reached out to
her in the wake of receiving death
threats and hateful negativity the only
murders in the building star says this
isn't what I stand for no one should
have to experience hate or bullying I'm
at that age where I feel like that's
what matters is making sure I'm healthy
and people are happy that I love of
course Haley and Selena's statements
stem from a messy month of social media
drama Haley explains in her post things
can always be taken out of context or
construed differently yeah take for
example this video cells shared last
month I accidentally laminated my brows
too much yeah after cell shared that
Kylie Jenner entered the chat posting
snaps of her and Haley's eyebrows
leading to speculation they were mocking
Selena but Kylie quickly stepped in
telling fans this is reaching no shade
towards Selena ever and I didn't see her
eyebrow posts Selena also cleared the
air writing agreed Kylie Jenner it's all
unnecessary I'm a fan of Kylie I want
them to know it's okay I was okay with
dealing with it as for Haley's takeaway
well she's got a PSA for the fans we all
need to be more thoughtful about what we
post and what we say including myself
the comment comes after a clip
resurfaced online of Haley gagging At
The Mention Of Selena's bestie Taylor
Swift full of the meanest lyrics about a
celebrity since Taylor Swift's last
album
meanwhile one of Hayley's BFF's Justine
Skye slams The Horrible narrative
they're navigating amid all the rumored
tension this isn't a game and it's no
longer funny Selena Echoes Justine's
plea I've always advocated for kindness
and really want this all to stop you
betcha you betcha and how's this for an
olive branch fans noticed Selena and
Haley are now following each other again
on Instagram I think my advice is to not
be afraid
[Music]